[Música]
quais são as motivações
quando eu comecei era a questão do
empreender do fazer e não
necessariamente o objeto pelo qual
acabei trabalhando a área ou segmento da
educação
mas aos poucos porque às vezes por mais
planejamento que a gente coloque o mundo
vai puxando de forma um pouco
desordenada a as nossas iniciativas
eu comecei a empresa os meus colegas de
faculdade que muitos participaram comigo
do movimento empresa júnior ea gente foi
pará através de um amigo em comum de um
colega que fazia parte desse grupo
na incubadora tecnológica de santa maria
mas antes disso com que surja essa
vontade de empreender pra mim que queria
ser um executivo foi o papel da empresa
júnior instigando esse processo todo
mas isso tudo aconteceu num momento de
confraternização socialização dentro do
pingo famoso parque da cidade no momento
tive surgiu uma empresa não tinha
negócio não tinha nada a ver com
educação não fazia ideia que isso ia
virar um negócio muito sério e que hoje
a gente afeta diretamente o nosso
trabalho
quase um milhão e meio de pessoas no
brasil então quais são as motivações às
vezes elas não são explícitas
elas são implícitas mas o importante é
algo que te mova é ter felicidade de
fazer se autorrealiza e isso me faz
trabalhar muito a cada dia sem ter é
nenhum arrependimento das coisas que a
gente tem que fazer do esforço muito
descomunal às vezes tem que se fazer
qualquer conexão como que eu vou para a
educação existe uma demanda
por parte das empresas lá no 2004 onde a
internet no brasil ainda é muito
incipiente mas as empresas já começavam
a ter uma demanda por capacitar
profissionais é usando tecnologia para
reduzir custos para tornar mais rápido
mais efetivo e vocês imaginam que em
2004 quando eu comecei um ano antes
daquela primeira foto anne ninguém usava
o celular
cravam eu criava dentro da minha empresa
com os meus colegas soluções para
capacitação à distância que não tinha um
dispositivo móvel associado
eu lembro que a gente fez os primeiros
as primeiras soluções de desenvolvimento
para grandes empresas farmacêuticas é
ainda no palm ainda nuno rebelde que não
se pensava em smartphones
algumas soluções bastante rudimentares
mas que já se usava para capacitar
vendedores é dispersos geograficamente
aí por essas andanças da vida sou
conectado um grande grupo empresarial
que adquire a nossa empresa nascida em
santa maria ea gente começa a olhar mais
para o mundo do ensino já trabalhava com
o ensino ea educação nas presas ainda
trabalhamos muito com o setor mas o
nosso coração é hoje ajudar as
instituições de ensino a entregar uma
melhor experiência de ensino
aprendizagem onde a gente consiga ter
retorno financeiro
obviamente como professor falou mas que
ao mesmo tempo a gente consiga entregar
isso com qualidade proporcionando algo
diferente e aí eu olho para esse mundo
da tecnologia
e vocês todos aqui têm celulares
o mundo está cada vez mais móvel e
educação também
agora a gente convive numa transição que
é de mundos que vai haver uma
convergência na sequência
então como
como trabalhar com o aluno que tem um
extrator
antigamente era conversa paralela agora
o celular como tornar ele papel apoiador
e ativo nesse processo
então o aluno tem uma necessidade
a gente tem um objetivo eles também têm
o objetivo é só repensar mas quando a
gente estava naquele momento ou muitas
vezes quando a gente volta pra esse
momento a gente sofre das mesmas
questões
o tento tive com um um grupo de altos
executivos
eu sendo parte disso e stefan num
processo formal de educação
um dia a gente tinha o mesmo problema
onde nós como alunos usavam celular o
tempo inteiro a favor do processo de
ensino ou não era algo que os
professores vão trabalhar ea tecnologia
parte disso parte do ensino era online
antes
depois de um momento presencial no
campus na semana voltava online
novamente e trabalhava em grupos
remotamente e depois voltava para
finalizar de forma presencial
assim será o ensino do futuro uma
convergência entre os dois e não um ou
outro e aí eu olhe um pouco do que a
gente faz do que a gente vê de tendência
hoje o winter ágil na minha posição com
instituições de ensino do brasil e do
mundo
a empresa de tecnologia que a gente
chama de téchiné mercado chama
carinhosamente assim e eu vejo coisas
muito interessantes sendo feitas
vejo a empresas locais por exemplo tem
uma empresa gaúcha muito interessante e
me salva que tá tendo já teve
investimento pra se tornar uma empresa
maior empresas é trabalho com
aprendizagem adaptativa como geek e nós
também desenvolvendo várias coisas
fazendo parcerias trazendo coisas locais
trazendo parceiro
internacionais e tudo isso tá
coexistindo dentro dessas questões que
eu coloquei aqui personalização vai ser
o primeiro tema que eu vou falar o que é
isso
negócio pra ser interessante isso
aprendi nessa evolução entre
empreendedor aqui em santa maria onde a
gente trabalhava muito no modelo de
serviço
eu aprendi muito nesse processo de
aquisição a que eu passei
onde eu vi que o negócio ele precisa ter
escala
só que a escala muitas vezes ela tira a
tua identidade do meu cliente nesse caso
como criar um modelo que permita
personalização e escala mesmo tempo ea
gente quebrando a cabeça para ajudar
instituições de ensino fazer educação à
distância a gente chegou num modelo que
a gente consegue coexistir é esses dois
mundos e hoje a gente nesse modelo que a
gente lançou há dois anos atrás a gente
já tem quase 70 instituições de ensino e
200 mil alunos usando soluções que co
existem entre viver um conteúdo digital
viver ea de um aluno que está mudando
muito a sua forma de interagir um
conteúdo que o processo de ensino
aprendizagem é que eu mostro um pouco a
gente faz isso que é uma idéia de um
lego de conectar conteúdos de diversas
fontes
mas permitindo a instituição de ensino
tem a flexibilidade que às vezes um
grande grupo tem o poder de investimento
e ela não tem
e assim ela consegue fazer e
principalmente não esquecer do papel do
professor da metodologia trazer
metodologias inovadoras conectando com
essas soluções se permitindo que a gente
consiga realmente tem uma experiência
que faz a diferença na vida do aluno ea
gente fez pesquisas que comprovam
que um modelo híbrido de ensino vivendo
tecnologia com o mundo presencial
eles são mais efetivos de um modelo
puramente presencial puramente
tradicional seja isso gera mais
aprendizado do aluno e portanto é uma
forma que a gente tem que incorporar no
nosso dia a dia
isso a gente tem visto as pesquisas
comprovam que cada vez mais eu vejo
instituições indo nesse caminho e
repetindo um case de sucesso que outras
já trilharam basta pensar em como fazer
ter cuidado ter calma mas tem iniciativa
de fazer não pode achar que o novo vai
bloquear e aprendizagem adaptativa hoje
a tecnologia nos permite criar modelos
de interação 1 onde eu direcionei o
aluno naquilo que é mais frágil
então por exemplo com esse preparatório
promenade que o exame que avalia os
alunos no final de seu superior
nós criamos uma forma de poder
direcionar o aluno para as suas
fraquezas e ele desenvolver aquelas
habilidades onde ele tem é mas maior
carência desenvolvimento e isso permite
rodar instituição de ensino a resolver
problemas do seu dia a dia mas também é
porque isso vai ser uma acreditação do
ministério da educação resolveu efetivo
problema do aluno que aprender
então isso não usa só para a finalidade
é coletivo usa no processo ensino
aprendizagem ao longo do curso
isso dá flexibilidade
isso dá autonomia e independência
professor conduzir melhor o seu processo
maria é na federal na própria
universidade federal e senti isso na
pele
chegar numa turma assim e poder
identificar qualquer carência do aluno
rafael qualquer carência do aluno
quando te ter quando tem tecnologia
estudar escala inter dar uma precisão
muito maior
basta saber usar e o aluno que se sente
beneficiado com isso também vai
valorizar
ele valoriza o professor que sabe usar a
tecnologia porque ele como usuário vive
esse mundo e muitas vezes agora quando
eu enxergo professores entrando nesse
mundo da tecnologia n próprio próprios
enxergam o valor que isso tudo torna a
sua vida melhor e como ecrã engajamento
porque jogar simplesmente a tecnologia é
um problema ela tem que ser jogada com
um planejamento com método porque se
messi não simplesmente do criciúma uma
retoma uma réplica dos problemas aula
presencial sem a socialização e sem a
proximidade sem o calor da educação
presencial
então hoje existem ferramentas para isso
que a gente vê em gaza gerando e
colocando à disposição das instituições
de ensino que são coisas que estão por
aí que permitem às instituições aos
alunos fazer isso de forma a engajar o
aluno lugar só que isso tem que ser
trabalhado professor para que ele saiba
usá la
por exemplo existem recursos de que me
queixo um ser humano é é ele ele
trabalha com estímulos ele é competitivo
na natureza por exemplo quando a gente
criou essa solução pra nade preparatório
enade
a gente colocou o ranqueamento é
incentivo através de recompensa e isso
gerou um mecanismo muito interessante
que a gente está levando para outras
soluções que a gente está criando o que
acaba gerando engajamento e engajamento
ao natural
os alunos é isso que eu chamo de usar a
tecnologia a nosso favor
e hoje a olhando para o papel da
instituição de ensino na interação com o
professor e aluno
existe o bebedeira a tecnologia está aí
à disposição e ela permite fazer análise
daquilo que está dando certo e daquilo
que está dando errado
é óbvio que informação é e dados para
análise sem propósito ou que
simplesmente o senta em cima desses
números não serve pra nada tem que tomar
uma atitude uma ação com isso
cansado de ver alguns exemplos onde a
instituição os professores têm
informações riquíssimas a seu alcance e
não tomam atitude e como tudo na vida
então aqui alguns exemplos que
ferramentas que existem no mercado
existem diversas permitem analisar o
desempenho dos alunos e atacar
deficiências específicas e direcionar
melhor o trabalho do professor é esse o
trabalho que começou aqui em santa maria
que hoje a gente interage com bilhões
mas cerca de um milhão e meio de alunos
no brasil de coisas que foram criados
aqui e isso tem espaço pra outras
empresas a explorar em diversas questões
relacionadas ao processo de ensino
aprendizagem que ainda não foram bem
resolvidas porque é um ecossistema
riquíssimo
o brasil tem muito ainda por educar é um
país com gripe e educacional muito
grande e tem muito espaço para isso
nós lá na empresa onde a gente é
trabalho e que ficou foi preso que
adquiriu a gsi que surge aqui em santa
maria
a gente vê oportunidade para muitas
coisas mas é um mercado riquíssimo
porque ele te dá propósito
e ao mesmo tempo te dá uma remuneração
terá dinheiro que todos nós aqui como
diz o professor eduardo buscamos também
então o que eu gostaria de concluir é
que a educação cada vez morre eu mais
móvel aí pra ficar
existe um mundo a ser explorado e dentro
por empreendedores que queiram buscar
soluções por um processo de ensino
aprendizagem mais efetivo ao mundo que a
receita começando essa é ao panorama do
que a gente construiu nesse processo
todo
eu tenho bastante orgulho de poder sair
daqui de santa maria criados essa
empresa que em santa maria e hoje elas e
parte desse ecossistema que influencia
quase um milhão e meio de alunos no
brasil através de centenas de
instituições e eu queria deixar uma
mensagem para finalizar e nem o menino
lá que falou que tem um é grande ele
admira muito steve jobbs infelizmente
ele não está mais aqui mas tudo o que
ele e deixou de legado ainda impacta
muita gente que é a questão de se manter
sedento 11 some na vontade de fazer a
vontade de realizar porque isso que na
verdade é o que nos move todos os dias
mas também não levar tudo muito a sério
no sentido é de que ser literal equipe
tem que aproveitar a vida dá risada
é isso aí tem que ter um pouco de
ingenuidade porque senão a vida muito a
sério
acaba machucando nos deixando ela muito
dura
então a minha mensagem aqui com steve
jobs é aproveitar a vida e fazer algo
que deixe a sua marca
nesse mundo obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]